[Music]
one of the mortal sins in the real world
is underestimating your opponent no
matter how the other guy looks or acts
nothing's ever set in stone until that
bell rings as the trite saying goes
don't judge a book by its cover and
while it's true in the real world it's
even more truer in the world of anime
yes a lot of us who are quite savvy and
knowledgeable no better than to
underestimate those comedic characters
but for someone who's uninitiated these
are characters you could have thought
were weak before the switch gets flipped
and these bad asses prove the detractors
wrong let's get started first in line is
ishin kurosaki
early bleach did little to help ishin's
case he started off being the overly
loud dad who seems to have no sense of
personal space he's also not afraid to
engage in shouting matches with ichigo
much to the annoyance of karin while he
can show a sentimental and serious side
ishin's mostly that noisy dad who's
there as part of ichigo's family to give
him an additional anchor to reality then
came the end of the seoul society arc
and we immediately see grand fischer
returning in an even stronger form only
to run into ishin surely the dad is
doomed right ishin makes short work of
grand fischer giving us the big reveal
that he's a shinigami one of the
stronger ones at that from then on he
continues to have a lot of cool moments
oftentimes fighting alongside his son
and most notably in the battles against
eisen
[Music]
next up is charmy from black clover
i know i know if we're talking black
clover ask that is the most obvious
inclusion but that's no fun right let me
tell you who else has a very deceptive
appearance that betrays any sense of
danger charming chimes all about the
food the air-headed girl is one of the
silliest characters in the cast and she
looks nothing more than a child she'll
neglect everything to satisfy her
appetite something that seems impossible
to do given her demeanor then someone
ends up pushing the wrong buttons and
the powerful charmy comes out you don't
get recognized as a magic knight for
nothing and charming won't hesitate to
demonstrate to anyone who dares to get
between her and her food she makes such
good use of her obsession with food in
combat and her food magic as well as the
new form that comes with it is truly a
sight to behold this little girl betrays
expectations like no other and that's
why she finds herself on this list
the pursuit of strength however isn't
limited to these characters like them
you can be this unassuming guy who turns
out to be a master of clans and strategy
under your command new legends will be
born in this eye-catching rpg and the
sponsors of this video bloodline heroes
of lithus just when you thought you'd
seen it all in the world of mobile rpgs
here comes this contender giving the
genre a new spin bloodline heroes of
litas is a card based rpg that features
spectacularly realistic 3d graphics
bringing in western aesthetics with some
of the most fluid controls fighting and
collecting are some of the most
important parts in an action rpg but
what i really like about bloodline
heroes of lethal is that it takes the
customization aspect that rpgs are
lorded for that makes it such an
integral part of the gameplay this is a
game where part of mastering it involves
marrying bloodlines mixing and matching
in order to create the perfect champion
so whether you're on android or ios feel
free to try this game out right now you
can also scan the qr code in order to
know more about the game trying the game
out is fun but it gets even more fun if
you get started with a whole bag of
treasures so if you're up for more
rewards you can use my link in the
description to obtain a champion token
and a hundred thousand gold and that's
not all you also get 100 diamonds to
help kickstart your journey
bonji is up next
ah ranking of kings it's one of the best
anime to come out in recent memory it's
one hell of an underdog story starring
the plucky budgie it's not hard to see
why the story beats are like that just
look at the harmless guy there's no
question that bonji's the weakest
character in the series at the start
he's got zero combat affinity no
physical strength oh and there's the
hearing disability to cap it all off as
well but as the characters in the story
eventually learn there's nothing more
dangerous than to underestimate this
determined boy after all what he lacks
in strength he makes up for in his
insane agility eventually he gets better
and with despair's help he starts
learning the ins and outs of combat
becoming one of the most cerebral
fighters as the show progresses it takes
immense will to not only be unhampered
by physical disabilities but also make
the most out of circumstance and rise up
to prove everyone wrong ranking of kings
is such an inspirational story and you'd
be missing out by not watching it
biscuits a surprisingly strong mentor
[Music]
there are a lot of easygoing mentor
characters in anime those who take
things in their stride before showing
how powerful they are like gojo or
kakashi then there are those grizzled
all men like natero in contrast a
literal lolly like biscuit doesn't have
as strong of a first impression or
potential until she reveals her true
form things then turn scary biscuit's
true form has her put a complete 180
from her initial appearance and that
muscular form ought to give anyone
nightmares perfect for her training
sessions that feel straight from hell
biscuit's a very very powerful character
you won't be able to tell by just
looking at the girl who looks like she
belongs in some other genre and if
you're looking for someone to train you
she's one of the best and toughest
teachers you can ever get
if you were to pick someone to have you
back from the seven deadly sins the task
is quite easy you'd either go for the
main guy meliodus or someone more cool
looking like bun for someone who has
zero clue about the series and the story
he could be hard-pressed to immediately
gravitate towards eskino looking like a
lanky waiter guy and turning into an
armstrong lookalike won't turn heads
until you find out that he's the
strongest one of them yes this is a guy
who stood toe to toe with the best the
enemies can throw at him this is the
same guy that also gave meliodas himself
a run for his money eskenor is a
character who proudly boasts an
undefeated record considering the number
of fights he's in and the caliber of
opponents seven deadly sins has that
achievement is just insane esknow may
look the least threatening amongst his
comrades but he sure is the strongest by
far
and while we're looking at the seven
deadly sins why not transition to fma's
version
a lot of scholars consider pride the
greatest of the seven deadly sins so and
blame you for being surprised that its
representative and fullmetal alchemist
is this boy even with his ties to the
military it just came as a shock to have
this child be revealed to be pride and
that's largely thanks to his appearance
who would have thought that this boy
would end up being father second in
command celine bradley has a lot of
transgressions in the series for most of
the series it's hard to find redeeming
things about him when he spends most of
the time living up to the sin he
represents while all the other homunculi
have had their share of defeats through
brute force pride ends up tanking
everything thrown at him while looking
smug there's literally one way to defeat
him and that's to beat him from within a
feat easier said than done given his
demeanor all this madness in the form of
a child that would teach someone not to
judge based on first impressions eh
i know
[Music]
is pretty much the poster child of the
list's theme he's got everything that
makes you not want to pick him in a team
battle scenario the comedy character
through and through it's not easy to see
why everyone underestimates rock lee
then came the gara fight everyone knows
he wouldn't win the fight but the anime
sure did a master class on selling his
chances with the awesome showing he had
it feels like we got robbed with how he
lost nobody expected lee to put off all
those cool moves and no one expected him
to win against the arc villain of all
people but let's just say that he sure
earned himself a fair share of fans from
that fight i really wish lee had more
moments after that he's got some cool
scenes and all but the fight with gara
is probably the peak of his character in
terms of events that we're going to
remember him for still it's a fight that
people will remember to this day proving
how well it worked in terms of defying
expectations
[Music]
however let's not finish with rock lee
how about zinitsu instead
zenitsu is the opposite of a badass
supporting character if first
impressions are anything to go by
thankfully first impressions are never
meant to last and this cowardly boy
who's annoyed a fair share of people
turns out to be one of the most reliable
allies tanjiro can have by his side he's
got a badass moment early in his
introduction but few can beat the
showing he put on during the mount
natagumo arc despite his cowardice
getting the better of him entering the
ark when push comes to shove zenitsu
proves that he can throw it down with
the best of them despite being at that
state he was in he unleashes his
breathtaking thunder breathing technique
in a moment that's become quite
underrated solely because this is the
same arc the famous dhanjiro versus rui
fight is him amongst the characters i
listed it's zenitsu who outright a
crybaby and a coward there are guys who
just look threatening or are simply
jokesters but zenitsu takes the concept
of a character who's stronger than he
looks to a whole new level that's why i
think it's great to finish with him
but is dinitsu the most drastic example
of a character a lot more badass than
appearances suggest or do you have
someone else in mind i'd love to know
your opinions as well as some feedback
on the list overall i prefer reading
them on the video comment section but
you can connect with the team on social
media as well all the links are posted
in the description and whichever avenue
you prefer to connect with us will
appreciate it you can find the link in
the description to download our sponsors
game bloodline heroes of lethars so go
and check that out too for now however i
thank you for watching this video make
sure to subscribe and share the video
with your friends and i'll be seeing you
next time